what is your current diet is it like you
still try to hit your 200 grams of
protein per day and then you just like
backfill with whatever you want and
dessert and like dinner or whatever that
ends up being 100 that's all I do 200
grams of protein and then I just
backfill my calories with whatever I
feel like what are your primary protein
sources so my breakfast and my lunch are
always the same I usually knock down
like 150 by lunch I do that bar in the
Shake in the morning he's the pre-made
the Box ones that are like a buck I just
do that it's easy I have the beef in the
in the steak like what eight ounce yeah
usually 12 ounces or 16 ounces anything
with that ketchup and then your dinner
is like whatever you and Layla feel like
eating basically yeah okay so we'll go I
mean we go out every night I usually
have a meat and a carb and a bunch of
bread appetizers and dessert and I do
that all the time and that's fine that's
like what we do you know it's like we
enjoy that